on soit tous bonsoir bonsoir alors on ne
va pas beaucoup de temps on va essayer
de faire rapidement et concis alors on a
eu une belle soirée ce soir oui oui la
rébellion pourquoi pas
voilà mon nom il convient pour ceux qui
ne me connaissent pas et dieu sait s'ils
sont minoritaires
là sachez que c'est mon vrai prénom ne
me demandez pas d'où ça vient je n'en
sais rien tout ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que ma mère est fan de scrabble
j'imagine pour le choix de mon prénom
elle devait jouer une partie un soir il
nous restait quatre lettres des merdes
qu'elle savait pas [ __ ] elle est
admise sur ma carte d'identité bonsoir
ça merci alors les tentatives
d'applaudissements c'est soit que tout
le monde soit de personnes
pas d'initiative personnelle je vais
vous demander de vous lever d'abord un
allah pour faire un petit rappel de tout
ce qu'on a eu
voilà ensuite regarder votre voisin
demandez lui s'il a joué à un jeu
récemment et maintenant racing et vous
voilà tout le monde sera soit maintenant
riez riez applaudissez mois stop stop
stop
voilà vous faites tout ce que je dis
donc ce n'est absolument pas un public
rebelles voilà
ainsi je fais un petit peu brossé tout
ce qu'on a vu ce soir donc on a eu on a
eu elodie elodie comme elodie moi je
suis souvent amené à représenter la
belgique enfin je représente les
couleurs du droit je représente qu'une
des couleurs du drapeau
autre point commun avec elodie c'est que
je suis souvent appelé je ne sais pas
pourquoi l'humoriste qui monte alors que
je ne fais pas d' escalade et que je les
monte personne autres autre grand moment
à un voile a eu alors qu' à draguer sur
internet en vol après je voulais pas
encore posé comme question qui à draguer
sur internet récemment applaudissent et
ceux qui ont dragué sur internet
récemment qui est allé sur facebook ce
soir qui est allé sur un sudoku ce soir
c'est bien ce qui me semblait tout le
monde ment alors autres moments
intéressants regardez le alors voilà
ronnie au nivellement ronnie bellman le
professeur rosny bellman ce qui était là
et je voudrais le dire bravo parce que
être aussi intelligent et s'appelait
ronis est déjà un acte de rébellion
alors amitié entre les peuples bien sûr
big up à david martin david martin le
chef étoilé qui nous a démontré que pour
être chef étoilé il suffit d'aller
passer quinze jours au japon et
d'épouser une belge voilà pourquoi pas
je poursuis je poursuis je fais vite
rapidement
marion marion nous a parlé de son film
sur les femmes qui font du surf en iran
donc les femmes qui font du surf en iran
moi j'appelle ça de la planche à voile
tout simplement
je suis professionnel n'essayez pas de
le faire chez vous
alors si je suis là comme l'a dit idriss
idriss et comme l'a dit également
l'enfant pavés et driss et l'enfant pas
vu l'on dit si je suis là c'est parce
que je suis content d'être d'avoir été
invité mais là la raison principale pour
laquelle je suis devant vous c'est bien
entendu l'abolition des esclavages
période pas particulièrement drôle dans
l'histoire
même s'il ya eu de nombreux humoristes
esclaves à l'époque qui n'était pas payé
beaucoup qui était payée littéralement
des cacahuètes
je pense notamment à bonaventure
washington ce célèbre humoriste esclaves
qui disait à juste titre le seul
avantage d'être payé les cacahuètes
c'est qu'on peu chier des sneakers ça
marche aussi avec les bounty mais alors
il faut manger évidemment des noix de
coco je poursuis je poursuis
j'espère ne pas être ridicule ni
dangereux en tout cas ce qui est évident
c'est que vous allez rien je poursuis
ton j'ai entendu aussi coding coding is
easy j'ai décidé de rebaptiser le slogan
cody six years il ya eu des moments de
poésie des moments de colère qu'on a
envie de suivre des cascades
voilà du tag du graffiti magnifique
il ya eu également du rap du rap avec
avec l'enfant pavé alors le rap c'est
très bien
l'europe c'est très bien regardez qu'est
ce que j'ai marqué j'ai un point commun
avec l'enfant pavé j'ai grandi dans une
cahute au katanga
j'étais moi-même enfants soldats et ma
mère se levait toutes les nuits sous un
soleil de plomb pour aller creuser la
terre avec ses dents
afin de recueillir quelques graines de
cacao qu'elle allait revendre aux
chinois tout ça pour qui pour quoi pour
vous pour vos kinder bueno kinder bueno
qui sont fabriqués avec du lait je vous
rappelle que le lait de erwin est quand
même meilleur donc n'hésitez pas un
alors qu'est-ce que j'ai ouï alors oui
ça y est voilà je fais des blagues un
petit peu sur l'afrique
on peut pratiquer de temps un petit peu
d'humour raciste moi je le fais de temps
en temps alors faites comme moi fait un
racisme et équitable le principe du
racisme équitable c'est que pour chaque
blague raciste à laquelle vous riez 5
centimes sont versés un petit producteur
de lait au burkina faso
et cinq autres centimes vont à my moon à
cette jeune malienne qui tous les matins
sous un soleil harassant parcours les 30
km qui séparent son village du puy pour
approvisionner son village en eau me
vient alors cette interrogation les amis
pourquoi ne pas construire le village
autour du puits maimouna une belle leçon
de courage mais qu'est ce qu'elle est
con alors et l'humour raciste fédère
toujours autant alors j'ai également
noté une particularité ce soir c'est que
l'idée de faire ce thème rebellion ne
pouvait se faire nulle part ailleurs
qu'en belgique finalement parce que vous
savez la belgique est une terre de
rebellions la belgique est un est une
nation de rebelles et de surréaliste
vraiment c'est à dire qu'on cultive le
surréalisme est de la rébellion
moi même je suis belge non pas depuis le
début je vous explique je suis né
zaïrois ensuite je suis devenu congolais
parce qu'entre temps le nom du pays a
changé
et puis je suis devenu belge parce
qu'entre temps le nom du pays a changé
j'imagine que dans 20 ans je serai
marocain
je plaisante
je serai polonais évidemment je
plaisante je serai peut-être syrien
gabonais ou libyen ou tchadien peu
importe pourvu que dans 20 ans je suis
un citoyen du monde
alors je vous parlais de ce fameux
surréalisme j'ai décidé de rassembler
pour vous quelques images qui évoquent
le fameux surréalisme et donc le
caractère rebelle du belge vous allez
voir quelques images ici soyez très
attentifs on va aller lire ensemble la
tension va démarrer que la première hop
regardez je vais vous demander de d'être
très attentif si ça c'est pas de la
rébellion
on va là lire ensemble tunnel belliard
le passage est difficile de 20 heures à
13 heures à français mais il est
difficile de 20 heures à 14h30 en
flamand que faut-il en conclure
eh bien le caractère rebelle c'est qu'il
n'y a aucune mention qui est fait pour
la communauté germanophone
on s'en fout on se fout complètement de
savoir quand le passage est difficile
pour les germanophones remarquer les
germanophones à travers l'histoire nous
ont démontré qu'il se fichait pas mal de
savoir si le passage était difficile
pour annexer un territoire étranger
amitié entre les peuples respect
évidemment autre caractère rebelle du
belge je regardais hop voilà ah le
fameux le fameux panneau regarder
bruxelles se trouve à 18 km en flamand
vers la gauche et à 22 km en français
vin la droite alors que faut-il en
conclure tout simplement que si vous
êtes pressés d'aller à bruxelles en
flamand a tout simplement à comment vous
dire en belgique on aime la précision
même la précision j'en veux pour preuve
ce panneau
on va le lire ensemble ce parking est
ouvert le lundi 24 heures sur 24 le
mardi 24 heures sur 24
le mercredi 24 heures sur 24 le jeudi 24
heures sur 24 le vendredi à vous y avait
pas de piège
le samedi 24 heures sur 24 le dimanche
24 heures sur 24 et les jours fériés
avoue qu'elle faut-il en conclure
et bien tout simplement qu'il est ouvert
tout le temps voilà mais on la famille
parce qu'on les rebelles pour ceux qui
ont encore des problèmes quant aux
heures et aux précisions
vous avez ce 6 1 voilà pour tout savoir
sur les paris à tout savoir sur les
abonnements les réservations les heures
d'ouverture et c'est comme s'il ya des
gens qui a peur disant bonjour je
voudrais savoir zéro parking est-ce
qu'on peut réserver une table
éventuellement je voudrais connaître le
type de revêtement dans le sol de ces
cadeaux c'est pour vous un autre
problème qu'on a en belgique c'est enfin
problème c'est pas du tout un problème
c'est que nous sommes confrontés dans un
pays trilingue des problèmes de
traduction parfois j'en veux pour preuve
cette boutique qui affichait sur sa
porte d'entrée ceux ci
on va le lire ensemble à l'achat de deux
paires de tongs à troisième est à moitié
cuite alors on ne sait pas du tout ce
que cette personne a voulu dire être un
vietnamien qui a pris en même temps le
flamand et le français voilà autre
problème de traduction
j'ai été confronté devant un restaurant
à ce menu
regardez les fameuses les fameuses
croquettes de morve à 8 $ 95 on met le
prix en dollars parce qu'on les rappelle
alors à l'intérieur du restaurant là je
suis tombé sur le menu sur le menu qui
affichait en numéro 18 ceux-ci regarder
le numéro 18
le le fameux gaspacho andalou avec juin
pour les toxicomanes gastronomes la
prochaine étape c'est l'oeuf à la coque
ce qui est des français ce soir jeudi
c'est les français les français sont
souvent steph par rapport aux belges
alors vous pouvez traduire un style un
petit peu coincé voilà le belge est
quand même beaucoup plus détendue j'en
veux pour preuve
prenons par exemple le 14 juillet vous
prenez le 14 juillet en france bon voilà
un c state s'est pas détendu voilà on a
flambé qu'il 1
flanqué il y en a qui ces dix jeunes
déguisés en général de gaulle c'est
festif pourquoi pas en belgique c'est
différent on est détendu on rebelles
voilà la prochaine étape c'est le marcel
le choc et les tonga moitié cuite
toujours le 14 juillet la tribune
officielle regarder voilà il ya une
stature elle a une qui est ému car
ébranla france voilà c'est le pays de
nabila de montesquieu tous à la tribune
officielle en belgique c'est totalement
différent on se marre regardez les
pelles émises n'importe comment aussi un
sens inquiétant qui pourra même pas se
défendre le programme il est par terre
elle elle se marre à mon avis lui a
raconté sa blague favorite c'est un
citron une vache qui rentrent cagoulés
dans une banque le citron dit plus un
geste et la vache personne ne bouge elle
se marre à côté l autre repas compris
mais la quintessence de la rébellion et
du surréalisme
je suis tombé dessus en me baladant dans
les rues de bruxelles devant une plaque
commémorative qui affichait ceux ci
on va là lire ensemble
c'est peut-être ici
déjà c'est drôle c'est peut-être ici
ep mondrian né à amersfoort en 1872 est
mort à new york en 44 décida de
retoucher une de ses compositions pour
qu'elle rejoigne les véritables couleurs
d'une photographie surexposé présenta
faut-il en conclure
et bien tout simplement que c'est
peut-être ici a dit qu'on connaît pas
fait un truc dont tout le monde se fout
mais on a quand même y ait des gens qui
viennent de loin et des gens qui
viennent de new york juste pour ça des
babys les ouvriers communaux qui ont
placardé ceci des jouets ce qu'on a mais
la plaque mais l'anraf yeux est sûr
c'est pas l'autre côté attend peut-être
raison et l'on vit c'est peut-être ici
que je devrais marc était d'ailleurs
tout cas j'ai été très content d'être
avec vous ce soir et avec tous les
intervenants de ce soir je remercie
toutes ces personnes qui qui nous ont
parlé devant vous qui m'ont inspiré qui
moyenne lui qui m'ont donné envie de me
battre c'est jamais facile d'arriver
comme ça et de faire un petit discours
c'est un petit peu comme un rencard 1
voilà vous êtes un petit peu comme un
premier rencart c'est à dire qu'on a
invité la gonzesse à dîner et un truc
est sûr c'est que l'addition on va la
payer
en revanche derrière on sait pas encore
si on va la [ __ ] ya un suspense la
différence avec vous c'est que en venant
ce soir et en payant votre place
l'addition vous l'avez déjà payé donc
même si à la fin du repas je ne vous ai
pas plus moi au moins je vous aurais
déjà [ __ ] et ça c'est très agréable
merci à tous
merci merci merci